اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير مشاهدينا
نحييكم الى بانوراما نناقش ابرز الملفات
وفي ملفاتنا لنقاش هذا المساء
هل نشهد عوده الزلازل في مناطق مختلفه من
العالم وهل هناك مخاطر من حدوث هزات ارضيه
في المنطقه
هل دول المنطقه مهيئه للزلازل ام ان كارثه
سوريا وتركيا تستدعيم مراجعه شامله
للمعايير الانشائيه وفحص هياكل الابنيه
القديمه
ودائما في نفس الموضوع ولكن في جزئيه
ثالثه كيف يمكن التخلص من الزعر وزياده
الوعي تجاه زلازل وما الاجراء الانسب على
حدوث الهزه الارضيه
[موسيقى]
زلزال جديد يفاقم الكارثه في تركيا وسوريا
اعلنت عن حدوثه اداره الكوارث والطوارئ
التركيه افاد مساء الاثنين وبلغت شدته
5.8 درجه على مقياس ريختر ضرب محافظه
هاتاي جنوب البلاد بيان افاد او بيان اشار
الى ان الزلزال تسبب بمقتل ثلاثه اشخاص
ومعلومات وزاره الصحه التركيه اضافت ان
المئات اصيبوا من بينهم 18 شخصا في حاله
حرجه تم نقل بعضهم جوا وبرا الى المشافي
القريب هذا كان جنوب تركيا اما في سوريا
حيث توفي خمسه مواطنين سوريين بمحافظات
سوريه مختلفه نتيجه التدافع وفق المرصد
السوري كما اصيب نحو 500 اخرين باصابات
متفاوته وعقب زلزال تم تسجيله تسعين هزر
ارتداديه بلغت اقواها 5 درجات فاصل ثمانيه
على مقياس ريختر افادت وكاله انباء ان
زلزالا بقوه 6.3 درجات ضرب لبنان وسوريا
وفلسطين في ذات الوقت كما افاد المركز
الاوروبي المتوسطي لرفض الزلازل بان
زلزالا بقوه 4.6 درجات بقياس ريختر ضرب
ايطاليا اليوم
ابرز الزلازل التي ضربت بلدان في العالم
بعد السادس من فبراير الحادي عشر من
فبراير زلزال بقوه 5.1 درجه ضرب تايوان
واخر بقوه 6 درجات قباله سواحل اندونيسيا
دون تسجيل خسائر الثاني عشر من فبراير هزه
ارضيه باقليم الحسيمه في المغرب بلغت
شدتها 4.3 درجه دون اضرار الرابع عشر من
فبراير زلزال بقوه 5.6 درجه جنوب شرقي
رومانيا لم يتسبب باضرار او اصابات شعر به
سكان بلغاريا وصربيا
الخامس عشر من فبراير زلزال بقوه 5.7 درجه
قرب العاصمه النيوزلنديه
الخامس عشر من فبراير تعرضت مدينه المرج
شرق ليبيا لهزه ارضيه دون خسائر وهي الهزه
الرابعه التي تسجل خلال الايام الماضيه
السادس عشر من فبراير هيئه المسح
الجيولوجي الامريكيه تسجل زلزالا بقوه 4.3
على مقياس ريختر ضرب ولايه تكساس
الامريكيه من دون ضحايا
السادس عشر من فبراير زلزال هز كرواتيا
بقوه خمس درجات ونصف دون ضحايا
وقبله بساعات ذكر مرصد الزلازل الاردني ان
منطقه الشمال البحر الميت تعرضت لهزه
ارضيه جديده بقوه 3.4 درجه
استاذ جيولوجيا في جامعه القاهره ومن عمان
الدكتور محمود القريطي الباحث والمختص في
علم ورصد الزلازل اهلا بكم مع ضفايا
الكريمين واسمح لنبدا بهذا الجزء هو في
الواقع ثلاثه اجزاء متصله عما يحدث وما
نعيشه من الناحيه الجيولوجيه من الناحيه
العلميه وكذلك في اخر جزء من هذه الحلقه
من الناحيه النفسيه سابدا معكم بفهم او
بتبسيط
محاوله فهم ما حدث واسمحولي ان ابدا من
القاهره معك دكتور عباس دكتور عباس متى
نصف الهزه ارتدادا ومتى نقول بانها زلزال
الحقيقه هو في جميع الاحوال اولا تحياتي
لحضرتك ضيفك الكريم وكل الساده المشاهدين
سواء للزلزال الاصلي او
الارتدادات او نسميها احيانا التوابع هي
كلها في الاصل زلازل واحيانا التوابع
بتكون غالبا اقل شده ولكن احيانا يكون لها
تاثير لان الزلزال الاول وهو الاكبر
احيانا يؤثر في بعض المباني بشروخ وتصدعات
يكمل عليها التوابع حتى وان كانت
بشده اقل فاذا احنا دائما متعودين ان يكون
هناك زلزال كبير ثم يتبعه ربما ايام او
شهور واحيانا سنوات كما هو الحال سؤال
دكتور عباس الانتقال الى ضيفه من عمان
بالامس
ما شاهدناه وما تبعنا تفاصيله وصف
بالزلزال وقيل بانه هذا الزلزال ثاني بعيد
كل البعد عن الهزات الارتداديه التي تبعت
الزلزله الاول
هو في الغالب ان الارتدادات تكون يعني
قريبه من مركز الزلزال الاول او الاكبر
عندما يكون في بيئه مختلفه او على مسافه
كبيره فبيكون زلزال اخر ما حدث امس هو
مكان مختلف عن مكان سته فبراير بيبعد
حوالي 100 كيلو عنه وهذا المكان الجديد ده
قريب من السواحل وبالتالي لكن على نفس
الفالق الكبير وهو فالق شرق الاناضول وهذا
فعل قابيل طوله اكثر من 300 كيلو متر لكن
يعتبر زلزال الامس زلزال جديد على نفس
الفالق الممتد لاكثر من 300 كيلو متر
دكتور محمود ما الذي حدث بالتحديد لماذا
هذا الزلزال يقول خبراء ونحن تبعنا بعض
القراءات من بعض الخبراء يقولون بانه لن
يكون مع الاسف زلزال الاخير
هناك تداعيات وهناك مرحله ستفتح على زلازل
متتاليه هل هذا صحيح هل هذا دقيق ان كنت
لازلت معنا لانه فقدنا الصوره لبعض
اللحظات ولكن عدت لنا تفضل
حقيقه ما حدث يعني هو نشاط زلزالي على
الصدوع التي تكون على حدود
الصفائح في المنطقه الصفيحه العربيه
والصفيحه الاناضوليه والصفيحه الافريقيه
فهذه النشاطات تكون حقيقه لجهودات مختلفه
على حدود هذه الصفائح طبعا مناطق مناطق
شديده
الزلزاليه فحدث ما حدث عاصفه قويه نتيجه
تحرير طاقه كبيره جدا وايضا ما حدث في
البارحه نشاط اخر كبير حدث طبعا
امتداد لصالح الصد الاول كما ذكر ضيفك من
القاهره لكن منطقه اخرى
حقيقه يعني هذه المناطق شديده الزلزاليه
الصفيحه الا نظوريه تتحرك الى الجنوب
وبالتالي تؤثر على على عده مناطق من ضمنها
جنوب قبرص ومن ضمنها جنوب اليونان لانها
تصل دكتور محمود في الاصل في الاساس ما
الذي دفع او ما الذي حفز تحرك هذه الطبقات
او بالاحرى هذه الصفائح البعض يتحدث عن
عمليه التنقيب المستمره عن الغاز البعض
الاخر يتحدث عن تجارب هل ما نسمعه من كلام
مؤكد وقادر ان يحفز تحرك هذه الصفائح او
هناك تحرك ياتي مع الزمن ربما
ما حدث هو عمليات تحت سطح الارض ولا
للانسان اي دخل فيها هي عباره عن تحركات
نتيجه ضغوطات هائله يعني عندما تتحرك
الصفيحه العربيه الى الشمال
وتصطدم بالصفيحه ناضوليه وتحدث نشاط كبير
جدا لا يقل عن 500 قنبله نوويه معا تم
التحرير الطاقه هذا لا يمكن ان يكون
للانسان اي له فبالتالي الطاقه تحررت
نتيجه تحركات صدوع على هذه الصدوع على
حدود هذه الصفائح وبالتالي هي حركات
ارضيه نتيجه ضغوطات وتحرير طاقه زلزاليه
تفريغ الطاقه في هذا الشكل لابد ان يكون
داخل باطن الارض
بصفات طبيعيه
عباس هل يمكن القول بان هذا الزلزال او
تحرك هذه الصفائح سيفتح المجال لتحرك
صفائح اخرى نحن نتحدث عن الصفيحه
الناضوليه ثاني عربيه الثالثه افريقيه
ولكن نعلم بانه هناك صفائح اكثر عددها في
العالم لاتينيه الهنديه الى اخره هل نحن
قادمون على تحركات جديده قد تنسحب على
المنطقه
الحقيقه ان القشره الارضيه على مستوى
العالم يعني مكونه من سبع صفائح كبرى مثلا
القاره الافريقيه في صفيحه والاوروبيه
اسيويه في صفيحه اخرى
وهناك المحيط الهادي وغيره وهناك صفائح
صغيره يعني
الكتله الاناضليه او المنطقه التركيه هي
صفيحه صغيره يعني تقع ما بين صفائح كبرى
ما بين الصفيحه الافريقيه والاوروبيه
وبالتالي هذه الصفائح مثبته تتحرك سنويا
بدون زلازل فالكتله الاناضليه تتحرك سنويا
بمعدل من 2 الى 3 سم في اتجاه البحر
المتوسط وبالتالي عندما ينشط او يحدث
زلزال فانه يزيد من هذه الحركه وهذا ما
حدث في سته فبراير ان هذه الطاقه الهائله
ازاحت الكتله الاناضليه في اتجاه البحر
المتوسط ما يقرب من متر هنا يعني هذه
الحركه الشديده وهذا
الزلزال الضخم ذو القوه الكبيره اللي
تعادل ما يقرب من خمسين مليون طن متفجرات
ممكن بتشجع وتحفز بقيه الفوالق خاصه ان
هناك فالق شمال الاناضول بيلتقي مع شرق
الاناضول في اقصى شرق تركيا ممكن هذا
الفالق ينشط وبالتالي كان هناك تخوف ان
يحدث زلزال شرق اسطنبول كما حدث في 99
وبالفعل كان هناك يعني زلازل اقوى من خمسه
الاسبوعين الماضيين
لاسطنبول حصل اكثر من مرتين وبالتالي هنا
المنطقه بتنشط بسبب هذه القوه الكبيره
وممكن زلزال الامس هو من نتيجه القوه
الكبيره اللي حصلت في
كذلك يتساءل عن المنطقه والى اي مدى هي
معنيه كذلك بهذا التحركات دكتور محمود
هذه المنطقه نتحدث على منطقه الخليج نتحدث
عن المشرق بتحرك هذه الصفائح هل هناك
لن اقول يعني تنبؤ بشيء ما ولكن علميا هل
نحن معنيون بهذه التحركات
يعني يعني كما كما ذكرنا الصفيحه تحركت
يعني في حدود من سبعه الى ثمانيه متر في
المنطقه الشماليه هذا هذا يعني ان اطراف
اخرى من هذه الصفيحه حصل عليها تغيرات في
الاجهادات اما تزايد هذه الاجهادات ولربما
يحصل نشاطات هنا او هناك على اطراف
الصفيحه من عده جهات لكن هذا يبقى يبقى
احتمالات
قوه هذه الاحتمالات لماذا تتحدث عن
احتمالات وتتحدث عن ترجيحات لماذا العلم
يعجز على
قراءه
التحركات الصفائح وكيف يمكن ان تكون
تداعيات بعض الزلازل فيما مثلا نجح في
امور اخرى نجح في تحديد
الاحوال الجويه الى لماذا باطن الارض وكان
العلم عجز على تقييمه او على قراءته
يعني حقيقه ما يحدث في الجو من تحديد
لربما قبل بساعه وقل او او يزيد هناك هناك
مؤشرات تدل على ذلك وسلوك معين محدد
متجانس يدل على قراءه معينه لكن ما يحصل
في النشاط الزلزالي حقيقه ليس هناك اي
سلوك متجانس يكرر نفسه
بمعنى اخر هي اجهادات
تتراكم في جزء معين هذا الجزء عندما عندما
يصبح غير قادر او تصبح الصخور غير قادره
على تحمل هذا الطاقه الكبيره والقويه يحصل
تحرير الطاقه هذا التحرير حقيقه ليس له
مقياس وليس له سلوك محدد حتى يتم معرفه
متى تتم هذه
التصدعات وتحرير هذه الطاقه ولكن دكتور
عباس قد يقول بعضهم واسمح لي ان اتفاعل
معك بحسب ما قرانا من تعليقات وبعد قليل
كذلك سناتي على قراءه بعض التعليقات لاننا
فتحنا المجال لمتابعينا كذلك
ليشاركونا تساؤلاتهم تعلمون بان هذا
الموضوع هو موضوع محل جدل كبير من بين
التعليقات يقال بانه الاعصير مثلا وهنا
سؤال حضرتك دكتور عباس لماذا الاعصار حتى
وان لم تكن له ترتيبات دوريه ولكن يمكن
التنبؤ به يمكن قراءته يمكن حتى متابعته
بالساعات وبالدقائق متى سيصل الى سيمتد
ولكن الزلازل تعذر على الانسان القيام
بذلك لماذا
عندما نتحدث عن الزلازل فانا بنتحدث عن
اشياء في باطن الارض ونحن لا نستطيع ان
يعني نصل الى تحت في الاعماق اكثر من عده
كيلومترات نصف قطر الكره الارضيه اكثر من
6300 كيلو متر وبالتالي ليس لدينا معلومات
كافيه عن ما تحت القشره الارضيه وما حدث
ايضا في لب الكره الارضيه هذه اشياء
جميعها لم نصل اليها واحيانا لا يصلنا
منها عينات صخريه خاصه من لب الكره
الارضيه عندما نتحدث عن الاعاصير فهي
بتبقى يعني طيارات هوائيه او تيارات بحريه
تم رصدها ومن خبرات السنوات السابقه بيتم
حتى تحديد موعدها ونوته عارفين ايامها
وربما تزداد او تقل عن موعدها وعندما تظهر
العاصفه بيتم متابعتها بالاقمار الصناعيه
وبالتالي هنا من السهل لتتبع يعني هذه
الظواهر السطحيه او الجويه لانه لدينا
الاقمار الصناعيه
السماء والاجهزه الموجوده على سطح الارض
اما بالنسبه للزلازل الحيه متعدد الاسباب
الزلازل حركه الصفائح الارضيه ده يرجع الى
حركه الصخور من اسفل وهي صخور فيها بعض
المرونه وبالتالي القشره الارضيه بتطفو
على هذه الصخور وهناك الصهير اللي هو في
لب الكره الارضيه عباره عن صهير
وبالتالي نحن نتحدث عن اشياء كبيره للغايه
لا نستطيع ان احنا نرصدها بالتحديد وهناك
ايضا عوامل خارجيه لها علاقه بالشمس
وبالارض
باشياء كثيره بالاضافه الى ان جميع
الصفائح متحركه بدون زلازل فاذا العوامل
المعقده للغايه ولكن لدينا بيانات كافيه
ودقيقه عن كل منطقه ونحدد مدى الخطوره في
المناطق وشده الزلازل فيها طالما هناك
بيانات عن كل منطقه خلينا نتحدث عن منطقه
الخليج والمنطقه العربيه مثلا بحسب هذه
البيانات هذه المناطق كيف هو وضعها فيما
يخص التحركات تحركات الصفائح
وزلازل الله يبعدها عن الجميع ولكن كيف
وضعها
دكتور محمود دكتور اعذرني دكتور عباس
ساكمل معك دكتور عباس ساعود بعد قليل
دكتور محمود تفضل
دكتور عباس تفضل
وا حضرتك السؤال لو سمحت على المنطقه
الخليج المغرب العربي المشرق تحدثت عن
بيانات قادره ان تحدد متى او متى امكانيه
حدوث مثل هكذا الزلازل
اولا المعلومات عن منطقه الاناضول
والفوالق هناك فالق اخر
بيلتقي مع فالق شرق الاناضول وهذا الفالق
يسمى فالق البحر الميت في هذه المنطقه وهو
ممتد جنوبا الى خليج العقبه
والبحر الاحمر ثم الى القرن الافريقي مرا
به
اثيوبيا الى ان يصل عبر عبر تنزانيا الى
موزمبيق هذا الفالق الكبير وبيفصل مصر عن
السعوديه البحر الاحمر بيسمى الاخدود
الافريقي العظيم وامتداده وهذا مكان ايضا
للزلازل ونشاط زلزالي ولكن اقل حده من
الفوالق الموجوده في في تركيا لان تركيا
عائمه فيها الفوالق من كل جهه ولكن يظل
هناك نشاط زلزاله على في البحر الميت ولكن
اقل كثيرا مما يحدث في تركيا ومتعودين ان
هناك بعض الزلازل ولكن غالبا بيكون من
ثلاثه لاربعه ريخ